we live in a time where there should be
proof of ghosts a hundred percent how
are you gonna prove it bro what ghosts
have you have you ever experienced a
ghost this is the thing you talked to
Bobby Lee and he's like I saw a ghost
upside down in The Comedy Store window
the one time and I'm like Bobby no you
didn't yeah you did no comedy store's so
hot oh bro oh my God you can smell the
ghost I'm talking about right now is it
falling that man what are you what are
you talking about ghosts there might be
oh like I can't stand that kind of like
listen the only thing are you religious
I'm more spiritual than I say I am
religious oh spiritual okay now we head
somewhere spiritual how you just said
that I do believe that like this this
isn't all on accident I [ __ ] hope not
man you know I [ __ ] I swear to god
dude I will be so pissed after I die if
there's nothing that's just black like I
will be so angry man dude I am I wanted
I wanted like I was always like I don't
want to be I when I was a kid I was like
I'll be religious enough that just in
case there is nothing afterwards I won't
be pissed off like do I believe in God
okay but not so much to where I go to
church every week and then I die and
then I'm like for [ __ ] sake I could
have been jacking off on Sundays there's
a problem though the flip side of that
what if what if you get to the big
Pearly Gates he's like bro you can go to
church once I feel like in the club
that's actually a philosophy local
argument in philosophy about it's got
It's like a bat serious no I'm not it's
a bet that live a good life yeah
Pascal's wager's wager thank you and
that that you know that if you uh so you
live a good life in the in the event
that you get to the Pearly Gates and
you're like you're like you should have
done this you know but you say Hindu
right dude if you're living a good life
to get into heaven you piece of [ __ ]
you got to live a good life because you
want to live a good life
don't assault me but we need but people
are human beings need to understand
that's why they come up with this stuff
yes they need to understand they also
need to uh live for an elevated reason
we're not just animals doing what we
want all that but the religion five
years ago that's what I was doing
however
you you have to yeah it's like he's
gonna get you in front of the game he's
gonna be like just a second too late
it's like it's like when you go to TSA
they gotta be like we gotta Chris has
got to go through the other one yeah and
then like Brandon you have the clearly
Brendan has a clear pass go ahead oh you
don't have clear
Brendan Eric you guys are on Clearpath
TSA approved right uh Chris can we talk
for a second no Brendan you don't have
clear either